كل الجهود الروسيه لم تمنع نجاحات بودانوف
نقل الفوضى الى روسيا وتحقيق هدف زيلينسكي
الروس الان يتدمرون من الحرب والبدايه
كانت باستهداف صحفيين ومؤثرين داخل روسيا
بعض العمليات التي شهدتها روسيا نعم لقد
قام جهازنا باستهداف بعض الاعلاميين
والمؤثرين داخل روسيا لن اذكر الاسماء لكن
لدينا قائمه للشخصيات المستهدفه وفي كل
هذا النشاط الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
ونجاحها جعل الاصوات في روسيا تتعالى من
اجل تصفيه قادتها وهنا بالطبع بودانوف هو
الهدف الاول والاوحد
بعد سلسله الاعمال التخريبيه في روسيا
وعمليات الاغتيال التي استهدفت موالين
السلطه مثل دار يد
والتي تقف خلفها الاستخبارات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه كما تقول موسكو من اجل بث
الزعر والخوف بين السكان رئيس الاستخبارات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه كيرين بودانوف يصبح
الان في روسيا هدفا مشروعا للاستخبارات
الخاصه الروسيه ولقوات الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه ولاي شخص كان دعوات تناقلتها
صحف وبعد وسائل الاعلام الروسيه الى
الدوله من اجل ان تظهر القوه من خلال بعض
الاعمال الجاده التي من شانها ان تعقد
حياه الهيكل العسكري للعدو وليس فقط من
خلال التمركز على طول خط التماس
لماذا هم احياء بودانوف على قيد الحياه
لماذا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني على قيد
الحياه لماذا هؤلاء الارهابيون احياء
دانيلف الى حد الان على قيد الحياه لم
نوجه الى حد الان ضربه مباشره لمراكز
القياده النازيه انهم بشكل مباشر يستهدفون
الشرطه وقاده المناطق الذين عينتهم روسيا
وبالرغم من اعترافهم بالوقوف وراء التفجير
جسر القرم واستهداف بيل جورد
لكن كيف نجحت اوكرانيا في تنفيذ عمليات
داخل روسيا اوكرانيا بقيت جزءا من روسيا
لمده خمسه قرون فتره كافيه لامتزاج السكان
الذين تجمعهم الكثير من الامور المشتركه
من الدين واللغه والتقاليد يعيش الان ما
بين اربعه الى خمسه ملايين روسيا من اصل
اوكراني في روسيا هم متغلغلون في الاداره
الروسيه والجيش ايضا وكثير منهم مستعد
لخدمه كييف وبطرق غير متوقعه احيانا مثلا
مع بدايه الحرب تفاجا الروس بالصحفيه
مارينا
وهي ترفع لافته مناهضه للحرب اتضح لاحقا
ان اصلها اوكراني ولدت هناك لتنطلق مشكله
روسيا مع مزدوجه الجنسيه ومنذ اندلع الحرب
اكثر من مليون لاجئ اوكراني دخلوا روسيا
الكثير من العمليات التخريبيه يقف ورائها
النازحون من اوكرانيا ولذلك يدرس البرلمان
الرو سي حاليا اصدار قانون يحد من حركتهم
داخل البلاد فئه اخرى مواطنون روس معارضون
للحرب او تم شرائهم من قبل الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه اغلبهم من المتقاعدين او
المراهقين او الائمه العملاء المدربين فقد
كلفوا بتنفيذ العمليات الاهم
[موسيقى]
اخر على النجاح وما يحدث اخيرا في بلغرود
الهجمات الاوكرانيه على بالقرود بدات
مباشره بعد سقوط بخموت ولم تتوقف طيله
الاسبوع الاخير من شهر مايو استهدفت
والاستهدافات فقد شملت كل المناطق التي
تقع في مرمى المدفعيه الاوكرانيه وهي
مناطق حدوديه تقع جنوب بيجرود ويبلغ تعداد
سكانها نصف مليون نسمه في الثلاثين من
مايو استهدفت اوكرانيا موسكو من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بثمان مسيرات ولكن وبسبب
طيرانها المنخفض
خمسا منها بانظمه الدفاع الجيش الروسي
استخدم ايضا انظمه التشويش الالكتروني
بسبب طيران ثلاث منها وسط البنايات وهذا
الهجوم لم يخلف اصابات لكنه بالطبع حمل
دلالات رمزيه
[موسيقى]
بلجيكا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات